the most unexpectedly uplifting and
consoling artists of the 20th century
was the abstract painter Mark rothko the
high priest of grief and loss who spent
the latter part of his career turning
out a succession of sublime and somber
canvases that spoke as he put it of the
tragedy of Being Human
born in Vince Russia rothko emigrated to
the United States at the age of 10 and
immediately grew to despise the
aggressive good cheer and Steely
optimism of his adopted land appalled by
the sentimentality around him rothko
learned to make art that was insular
unrelenting somber and oriented towards
pain
rothka's favorite colors were a burnt
burgundy dark gray pitch black and blood
red occasionally alleviated by a sliver
of yellow
in 1958 rothko was offered a large sum
to paint some murals for a soon to be
opened opulent New York restaurant The
Four Seasons on Park Avenue it was as he
put it a place where the richest
Bastards of New York will come to feed
and show off
his intentions for them became clear I
hope to ruin the appetite of every son
of a [ __ ] who ever eats in that room
and to that end rothka set to work on
some large black and maroon color Fields
expressing a mood of Terror and archaic
anguish
however shortly before the paintings
were due to go on display rothko had a
change of mind called up his patrons
explained his feelings and sent back the
money he then gave his paintings to
London's Tate Gallery where they were
hung in a quiet Airy contemplative
seeming space that enclosed the viewer
in an atmosphere of meditative
mortification the paintings remain ideal
companions for visitors who drift Into
The Gallery at their wit's end who might
be working through the loss of a partner
or the Rune of their career and who need
more than anything else to know that
they are not alone
rothko's canvases though focused on the
darkness are never themselves depressing
to look at because they lend our
difficulties dignity and legitimacy to
bathe in their atmosphere is to gain a
distinct sense of comfort like lying in
a tender person's arms who says little
other than a modest I know in response
to our dejection and loss with rothko as
our guide our pain and sorrow can matter
a little less we can start to ReDiscover
a taste for life when we see that we're
not alone in finding it all very hard
that it is acceptable even necessary
sometimes to hate The Smiling bastards
who so annoyed rothko we can build
friendships imaginative or real around
shared honesty about dark things
unhappiness is just as wise artists have
always liked to remind us and despite
the suggestions of all those confident
seeming people congratulating themselves
in the world's fancy restaurants very
normal indeed